[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh hey welcome
back to the break room everybody we're
thrilled to have you here on a Friday
hoorah
the record I don't know why I did 90s
Pacino there uh the break room of course
is our daily uh nerdy news show keeps
you updated on everything you want to
know live from New rockstars actual
break room uh coming up today we're
still AGA not Gaga but a guy at that
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 trailer
that dropped yesterday there's so much
to talk about we have a bunch to get
into and with me to do that today
Brandon Barracks here oh hello uh
Jessica Clements is here you're by
popular demand by popular demand Demand
by uh unpopular demand Tommy bechtels
here refuses the lead yeah
uh don't forget to come see me on Sunday
oh yeah we're gonna get to that for sure
um and and we are doing we're doing a
Redemption today uh we've got a wheel
behind time
popular characters
um we're gonna spin that every fifty
dollars we raise in super chats and do
an impression of that character uh maybe
an impression of that character doing
something specific yeah yeah yeah we'll
tear up with a question like a press
conference yes these are all characters
oh yeah you could do like a Comic-Con
because he's all the people that were at
yesterday's commentary there we go the
details are slowly coming out on me yeah
we'll have it ironed out by 359. yes um
and as Tommy mentioned the four of us
plus Eric Voss heard of him plus I'm
screen producer John oh plus a couple
other folks you might recognize are
going to be at La Comic-Con uh this
Sunday 10 30 a.m room 402a uh should you
be looking uh doing a live in person
break room show you know how I do it
live signing graphs and taking baths
baby I got a full-size bathtub you could
have gone a different direction
yes I'll be doing maths and uh uh
petting giraffes I'll be kicking ass you
guys yes come see us I'll kick your butt
they'll they'll be there'll be some
audience interaction elements there'll
be some prizes to win we've got a lot of
fun stuff planned so this Sunday two
days from now basically uh 10 a.m come
by in 10 30 a.m come by and see us nice
and early L.A Comic Con yeah what are
you going to do when they show up oh man
I'm gonna just be so happy and just
filled with joy and celebrate life
that's the secret oh okay that's our
first impression guys we didn't have to
spin a wheel that's Brandon
impersonating a healthy person
oh
uh James Gunn uh of course he got on his
favorite social media platform Twitter
uh after that trailer dropped yesterday
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 and he
clarified some things uh he gave some
more background info
um of course there's that those great
shots of the Guardians in those colored
space suits our own Eric Vossen looks
other people had wondered if that was an
Among Us reference
um and he clarified that that was a
direct reference to 2001 A Space Odyssey
there are those suits right if you've
seen 2001 A Space Odyssey you know that
they um the spaceman in that movie uh
wear suits very similar to those
um do you think that was like the 50th
time he was asked like as he was
shooting the scene do you think people
on the set were like oh is this like
Among Us he's like no it's 2001 A Space
size
know what do you think about this move
well the thing is yeah it's also like
your movies coming out in 2023 uh most
people are watching it are between like
they started like 18. no one seen 2000
it came out that movie came out before
man was on the moon uh which yes I think
it was like 62. John will Google this
for us but um yeah years before we
stepped on the moon and like when you
when you re-watch that movie in that
context the special effects are insane
but uh Zach I'm gonna fight you on that
yeah we never stepped on okay 68. well
we're past conspiracy give me the
impression of Brandon again I'd rather
have that one we've stepped on the moon
oh there you go just the Moon built on a
soundstage yes no get out of here
um okay well and there's that other uh
shot right of Herbert Wyndham the high
evolutionary and there's a woman kind of
like running in a outer space you know
kind of upside down treadmill that is of
course also a reference to 2001 A Space
Odyssey
um and and this is what we're going to
be talking about later in this show and
spending a lot of time and having a lot
of fun with he posted on Instagram that
not all of the Guardians will be making
it out alive
completion of the trilogy the end of an
era we are Groot
um not all the Guardians will be making
it out of life tell me something it's
Mrs
j67362 is that like a real person or is
that a bot oh
a sock puppet it was a very body kind of
answer like uh actually you the creator
of this movie don't know everything
about the movie that you created those
characters will be back and then James
Gunn's like nah because I killed some of
them because it is my movie well and
we're gonna talk about there's a lot of
different ways that that could go and
impacts on the broader MCU that could
have
um we also got a poster for volume three
that dropped yesterday thank you
beautiful they're on the Bowie it's too
dark
Thanksgiving they're so tiny yeah and
and sorry can we pull the poster back up
uh Gamora is in the group yeah she's
there yes okay
so we know she's she's not in the
holiday special yeah presumably she's
not beginning the movie hanging out with
this crew Guardians no
and none of the shots from the trailer
beyond the colored spaceshoot shots and
maybe like one other battle scene is she
with the other people we saw like
there's a shot of her by herself right
or looking at the uh the photo not a lot
of know her interacting with Peter shots
well one of our esteemed co-hosts from
yesterday I can't remember if it was Jay
or Coy see your eyes does she start out
the movie working as a Hired Gun for the
higher evolutionary oh is she you know
is she Breaking Bad like she's always
used to before she joined the team you
know daughter of Thanos there was also
the fear that she's like part of the
ravagers or like leading the ravagers I
would like her to be leading
I almost sneezed I would like that was a
dramatic pause oh my God it's still
coming okay I I would like her to be I
would like her to be a part of the
ravagers lady in the ravagers and then
eventually make her way to the high
evolutionary and working with alongside
um Adam Warlock I also I hate to be that
person I want her to fall in love with
Adam Warlock
attractive and star-lord's constantly
looking at her like what in this because
Adam Warlock is a badass Adam Warlock is
a vicious maniac right now and that's
what Gamora also and and kind of dumb
and and maybe she's into that we don't
know yeah you call my boy warlock dumb
well he's he's been compared to a baby
mentally right he's literally born
yesterday he's just a baby okay well
babies are done oh wow it's confirmed oh
wow
you're a picture show guy's an idiot
boss baby was kind of smart who's who's
baby boss baby boss baby boss baby well
he's a boss Baby Geniuses literally the
franchise that launched a thousand ships
okay
are you talking about uh ships like
people uh standing uh two different
they're babies you can't stand them I'm
standing John Boy and who else is in
those movies uh Jeff Bridges
man could you imagine avoid Bridges sex
tape let's move on is Alec Baldwin the
voice of the bus baby yeah yeah it is
Baldwin he was he was yeah they might
have taken it away from him I'm so sorry
this tree is so tall I'm gonna make it
shorter keep going uh we got a couple of
super chairs oh my God you're murdering
that tree oh she's just uh topping it as
they say um Christian unpronounceable uh
sorry you can't make it to the LA
Comic-Con tomorrow no problem and and
thank you for the Super Chat Amy L open
the pod bay doors Hal somebody's watched
some Criterion I'm afraid I can't do
that yes uh Bucky Barnes ATL a couple
other folks sending super chats we
appreciate you again every time we hit
50 bucks we will spin the impression
wheel and really do some injustice to
some famous characters Jessica's
incredible at him yeah so vote for her
if you're gonna vote for anybody no you
guys do the best and Zach has never
shown she's practically she's a regular
Dana Carvey over here no I'm not
um stop what uh the the
um uh I was gonna say the Phil Hartman
but who's the other Rich Little the rich
little of uh of the ratio sounds known
for his Impressions Horatio among other
things
um uh real quick something you should
Google is uh daily nutrition needs our
friends at athletic greens yeah but
we've been sponsoring the show all week
long one of those packets I'm still
recovering yes
a little travel pack of ag-1 their
signature product again it's the
holidays maybe you're traveling maybe
you're eating holiday meals or partying
or whatever you're not eating all your
fruits and veggies and getting your
Perfect Blend of minerals and nutrients
you should be every day ag1 I did take I
took agu1 for my Thanksgiving trip I
took it every day while I was there oh
and I felt incredible I ate so much food
that's probably not a good idea but no
ag1 every morning I drank it and I was
like I can do whatever I want now I'm
Invincible yes you want to have some
holiday fun you best be taking your age
you want otherwise you're going to be F
you done yeah it is good though and
they've been sponsored us for a few
times in the last few months and I've
been taking it the entire time look at
you've never been healthy you do have
prettier skin thank you also uh if
anybody's clocking Brandon not had any
sick days that's true true I'm not I'm
not trying to say that eg1 will prevent
you from getting ill but
um and you know hey it's keto paleo
vegan dairy free gluten-free it's all
it's got all that stuff going for you
just you just drop this little packet or
you get a bigger bag and take a scoop
cold glass of water boom and you're
covered for the day
um and if you sign up right now
preferably using the link in this
video's description uh you get a free
year supply of vitamin D which is an
important nutrient especially in the
winter time because we're not getting
enough sunlight uh so reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition uh they're
gonna give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting environment D and five
free travel packs these little guys with
your first purchase all you have to do
is visit athleticgreens.com break room
again that's athleticgreens.com break
room to take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance thank you we will
be taking these before our appearance at
La Comic-Con to make sure we can fight
the concrete the dreaded concrete we'll
have a foot race and we'll see who's
fastest thanks to their ag-1 we could
talk about ag-1 all day folks but we got
to keep talking about Guardians of the
Galaxy this trailer that they really
shocked us with I did not think this was
coming this year I thought January at
the earliest unprecedentedly early they
put it out uh it was incredible we were
all very excited to see it looks great
uh but also looks like a a sad tragic
film because who is gonna make it out of
this movie alive right they're they're
killing people off left and right James
Gunn he's warning everyone he's saying
like look
not everyone's making out of this and he
famously did that with the suicide squad
where he said don't get too attached
yeah and there was half that cast from
the original teaser trailer Was Gone in
60 Seconds and the other half not many
of them made it to the end of them yeah
that's true yes and like a lot of of the
actors involved with the Guardians have
kind of been saying this is like the end
of the road right Dave Batista he put
out uh Instagram post after the movie
rap that said like hashtag goodbye Drax
uh and and you know when a lot of that
controversy was going on with James Gunn
and James Gunn was like out of the MCU
for a little bit Batista was very vocal
about like I work with James God and
like I'm not interested in like doing
stuff without him uh so I don't know and
like Zoe Saldana has recently given an
interview saying she felt stuck in
franchise movies now she's in 12 more
Avatar movies I believe uh you know but
she's also been in like the Star Trek
movies yes it was this I'm sure she did
say that and yeah for Avatar right right
I mean it's another 12 years yeah she's
hooked up to him
yeah but like she also you know her
character she's got to put on that
makeup she gets a lot more makeup than
like Chris Pratt who's rolling in uh out
of bed and they don't even gotta touch
the hair it's got to look tussled there
you go uh so yeah all these characters
seem like this could be the end of the
road right the end of their story so we
wanna we wanna put our money where our
mouth is or our yandus were our mouth
mouths are we got we got a Deadpool
folks I put a yondu in my mouth put it
on do in your mouth I got sick for a
week okay here's how it's gonna work
guys
no everyone sit there everyone sit there
Steve kornacki here okay so these are
like our big characters right
in this movie that we think have like
the biggest chance our main characters
yes the big nine or ten characters so
we're gonna assign some yanjus out of
them uh because yondu of course is dead
yes uh out of five yanjus five being the
most dead so that and and we're we're
saying they're they're likelihood likely
dying during volume three yeah this is
the Guardians of the Galaxy ah Deadpool
this is not a Deadpool movie and do we
have to explain how they died or just
that they're probably gonna die you
gotta convince me that they're gonna
okay okay and you're the ultimate
Arbiter of yeah but I know the answers
okay I've I've done the data I've done
my own research okay
did you yes because then why is Deadpool
in this movie this is not a Deadpool
movie Why would you put that image next
to it that anytime you write the word
Deadpool that appears yeah it's like
Twitter you should look above the Taurus
and made a different thing look up a
thesaurus I refuse do your own research
thesaurus for pool
um okay and I like I think it's it's
very appropriate that you led with Peter
well maybe with Peter quell yes come on
hear me out so we see him in the trailer
draped over nebula's arms yeah looking
now in the trailer breakdown which uh
Eric Voss did that's live on the New
York Stars Channel right now
um he speculated that Peter was drunk
have you been drinking sad about Gamora
okay
I don't know he looks like he could be
sick or dead he's not gonna show him
dead in the trailer he's too powerful
he's too powerful he's a half God right
he gave up his half God power oh he did
yeah they kind of gave him and then took
him away which I think makes him very
susceptible to death I think he lives I
think he lives I think he lives I I'm
not even giving I'm not even gonna give
him I'm gonna give him my vote is one
yondu I think there's like a one in five
chance oh I I there's maybe like maybe a
20 chance he dies and here's why
he of the characters in The Guardians of
the Galaxy he's one of the most
transportable right he's an Earthling he
has a connection to Earth a lot of the
terrestrial MCU movies Peter quilt a
Peter Quill without his Guardians is a
different Peter Quill as someone we
could see maybe in a in a future town
maybe in a Kang Dynasty or something
like that I don't think you kill the the
the reason for the season you know and
uh so I say I 20 chance that's just my
vote
hi hi chance Lo chance Peter Quill dies
I think low chance he dies higher chance
he just exits he leaves he's like I'm
done yeah I'm kind of leaning that way
it's more he retires yeah he will no
longer be the leaders of the Guard the
leader of the Guardians of the Galaxy
maybe he goes off and does something
else kind of like it's more of a Steve
Rogers exit than a Tony Stark exit
ambiguous he is done with the MCU but we
don't see him croak
um so I'll say one to two one to two one
two two one do two yonders okay until
tell us in the chat we'll be running
maybe a poll uh tell us what about one
and a half yonders then yeah
juice for Peter Quill Gamora come on she
doesn't wanna she's already dying but
she's already dying she's already dying
but but how better to make Peter Quill
retire leave than kill her twice I think
they go off together I think they I
think they go off into the sunset I
don't think it's gonna be her I think
it's gonna be her oh well don't step on
your later vote but I I like well kind
of what Tommy just said that her and
Peter end up together and then they go
up and retire a little bit of Eternal
Sunshine of the Spotless Mind energy
there I mean I mean Peter was always
kind of like in the first one he just
felt this loneliness and like they have
those moments together where he's kind
of trying to have on like a normal
relationship with this like you know
they're dancing and things like that you
know it's a little similar to to Captain
America just wanted to have a normal
relationship with Peggy you know as
normal as two Agents of Shield or
Avengers could have why not let these
two Guardians have a normal Cosmic
relationship and you know maybe doctor
strange and Clea bump into him in a
later movie don't make him swing maybe
they all throw their keys into a Giants
crazy it would be the killer twine no to
just not put her with Peter how crazy
and like how I think in the right way of
it being like yeah some girls just leave
dude it's okay and I think that would
set up Peter today Kitty later in the
future
[Music]
oh Katy Perry whoa okay yeah again I
think dead less dramatic effect if we've
already watched her die once on screen
right if she does again I'd be like okay
here's an easy one for you 50 on dude
dead put up put all the onions we have
braces dead break Beyond new scale he's
already lost his family not not based
off of anything that Dave Batista said
going off of nothing different not even
basically what I said on just his
character alone he's his tortured so his
whole family is dead he wants to join
them in whatever Drax and doesn't it
didn't it feel like making Drax and
mantis the centerpieces of the holiday
special might have served two purposes
kind of launching mantis as being an
important character later and maybe
giving Drax a little bit of final screen
time time before retiring I don't think
Dave Batista wants to be wearing that
body paint for the rest of his life and
he's got a he's talked about it has to
be such a good shape to be Drax uh like
shirtless Drax in those movies
it takes a lot to kill him eh because I
still think even if he is very depressed
he's like I have to fight to the last
minute and it's like I don't think
anyone's going out of their way to
direct the fight towards him but don't
you also see like like kind of as we've
seen in previous volumes like Drax
sacrificing himself jumping knives in
hand into the mouth of a giant monster
yes to save the rest of his team he's
powerful enough to kill Drax I want to
see that also also the stronger the
character the more heartbreaking when
they die right at least for for yondues
but yeah I think it should be five quite
frankly I I I do lean closely we can
always come back we could come back and
place a fifth one later if we need to
yeah okay four and a half whoa four and
a half four and a half yonders project
rocket rocket okay well this is the big
Rockets moving this is the big
speculation he in the trailer again Eric
and the trailer breakdown
he was saying not gonna die because it
seems like too obvious from the trailer
yeah I agree right there's the point he
looks like he's laying down yeah he's
like he's like
yes we're nothing uh and clearly we're
gonna see his origin or a lot about his
origin in this one yeah so maybe it
would make sense to go full circle and
to kind of then say goodbye to him I'm
saying he's not gonna die for a couple
reasons one
I mean it's just it's just such a great
character in the MCU it's also an easy
character for the actor to do Bradley
Cooper shows up and does three hours in
a in a vo Booth they sell a lot of
Rocket toys
um so a lot of group toys yeah and I
think like what about little urns with
raccoon ashes
he's gonna get a great Arc in this movie
that he doesn't need to die for it to
complete I think we're gonna end up with
a with a rocket and Groot uh animated
series for uh for Disney plus that's
gonna be voiced by Vin Diesel and
Bradley Cooper it's going to be like a
Prestige animation project that's my
prediction Harley Quinn style yeah I
think so something like that do you
think rocket makes it Jessica no I think
he dies whoa you're seeing dead I think
he just genuinely does I think this is a
full circle it does seem like and from
light from ashes come new life and I
think that new life is going to be with
uh Leila
Lila Lila and Cosmo I think we're gonna
get and I think think that full circle
moment happens when we see the altar
Earth with all the other people that are
animals that have also been like
genetically made to be humanist humanish
and I think that's just his or that's
his story it's just the same with like
how we expect Ant-Man to die it's the
hero's journey you need to go you need
to end eventually and I think he's going
to sacrifice himself he is also he's had
to watch group die a couple times he
would him and nebula were the only ones
who didn't get dusted and he had to live
through all of that and I did not that
attention and he won he's been like the
one who's had to learn to let this be
his family even more than Drax had to
drag spot in early but a lot of
Guardians who was still him learning to
be part of a family and I see like him
laying his life down well and you have
to imagine them introducing Cosmo Cosmo
kind of plays a similar role cuddly uh
creature I hope they slit that dog oh my
God we'll give rocket three three
you guys don't think so we think so okay
all right well technically a split would
be two and a half well we can do two and
a half yards no no go with three
two and a half but the top half of it oh
wow there you go I love hearing him
scream from from his uh speaker yeah to
not to his squeaker um okay uh from his
Mohawk from his Rift guard to his
mid-dripper
um Groot now I think we were saying
before he's already died uh we're just
seeing teenage Groot yeah we gotta see
like you know I'm just a teenage group
man baby
um I think less than one yeah I agree I
think Disney loves a baby Groot and you
know you kill a group you get a baby
girl you can't be doing that you know
what you know what Disney loves more
than a than a than a baby group a family
of groots and maybe our group grows up
and he has a little sapling of his own
wait group [ __ ] confirm does he [ __ ]
now that's deciduous uh whoa
like that one I don't think you need to
give him a Yonder no yonders for girls
zero zero yeah not everyone needs a
Yonder if if there is one Guardian that
survives this movie it's got to be
grooves worst case you just plan him and
he becomes a regular tree right yeah it
also yeah I guess he comes back so he
technically doesn't really matter we've
already seen him die he did a great
sacrifice
[Applause]
let's kill some of these MFS mantis what
do you saying well it would be a shocker
if she died yeah and the reason I'll say
I don't think they'll do it because like
you want to she's the one you want to
see mourn right the most because she
absorbs that grief from everybody and
reflects it and whatever so you know
maybe she I don't think she'll die
mantis dying would affect Drax a lot or
him dying that's it I also think that
she has the same powers that Peter cool
has we haven't seen it yet since her dad
is still a star they did just power her
up so I think it'll be too hard to
actually kill her and I think that time
we'll see her shine and that's the only
reason why I think she will kind of okay
sorry let me just interject one thing
would it be the ultimate sacrifice for
your newly found sister to restore your
powers that you gave up by giving you
her powers and her gift in order to heal
your grieving mind and and overpower the
leader of the Guardians of the Galaxy I
get it it's a woman Saturday yeah I was
like I understand sent you but it still
doesn't mean that they weren't going to
tell that story I think James Gunn
wouldn't do that to mantis I don't know
he said he's killing all of them or a
lot of them at least we got to kill some
of these people
some of these people here well I want to
skip I want to skip forward I I think
mantis is one is one yondu if you quill
Do It
um no uh I don't know what you're doing
John what are you trying to say Charles
to move on
yeah
okay we've got to do a Redemption all
right Jessica go ahead no you got to
tell me no you're the impression Master
let's see it yeah you can spin it you
don't have to do the impression how
about you spin it and then somebody will
claim the impression how about that also
that yeah it's like it's not a British
accent
oh how appropriate cradling Ragland
um we're almost that's very Southern
right all right I could do crankland
okay here we go no you can do a great
credit no no braglan tell us if you're
gonna die or not yeah I'm dead me
I'm dead as you get raccoon like there
will be in this movie my quill yeah I'm
graggling I can't stop peeing my pants
who would you house who would be who
would you be status about they better
slit back dog's throats that is about
losing not happiest
huh I said saddest about losing I'd be
really sad if I died
yeah yeah
in my pants I just never said that
what do you order at Wendy's
I'd like to order a big baked potato but
I don't eat it with my mouth I'm
surprised greglans eat anally oh my gosh
these old species I do want to I know
we're skipping order I do think Cragun's
gonna die I do too yeah because here
here's the thing we see that shot of um
Peter and mantis both like weeping
hardcore looking down like somebody's
maybe on an operating table or somebody
has died or something like that like
wouldn't it make sense like Cracklin
kind of like the scrappy Underdog
Guardian character that's been around
the whole time like also strategically
his brother yeah who hooks him up with
his roles is about to leave the
franchise you think if they do more
Guardians movies with a different
director you think they're going to be
likely to get uh James Gunn's brother in
there I think the fan is giving him a
brain tumor oh yeah
I'm putting 5G inside him for sure it
used to just sit on top now have you
seen it have you seen the YouTube videos
about the depopulation of people getting
brain Arrow implants so it's almost
connected to Gates guys for Google Bill
and Melinda finally at least five
yonders I put six behind the scale
I could do five Beyond dudes you know
it's like me when I stepped on my
childhood scale it's shattered
let's go okay now we gotta go back to
Netflix let's go back I don't want to
skip nebula nebula is a very interesting
thing yeah we've kind of caught we
haven't I guess we haven't seen her die
we've seen her tortured almost apart
yeah pulled into her whole life has been
pain and torture can she die though
version of her yeah and I will say and
it was just a shot she's had a great Arc
right from kind of pure villain to kind
of anti-hero to now she zooms just like
a good person although not Beyond
stealing a prosthetic arm from somebody
oh we don't know
what do you think she could have loved
her way oh traded smooches
kisses kisses
charms for arms I'll let you use the arm
on me but then I'm taking it so that's
quite the hand job oh my gosh I'd give
an arm and a leg
they better slit that dog's throat
you can't stop pissing my pants two dead
yonders for yeah sure because I only I I
don't think they'll do it but it might
be killing Side characters I don't like
it yeah yeah yeah that's great no no
nebula's my favorite character all right
now this one also Karen Gillen is not
out in the Press complaining about
another makeup that's true she's like I
love [ __ ] made a tick tock account and
she she just talks to everybody about
being nebula and I was like oh my God
she wants to do it because she's a nerd
in real life like she's a real life nerd
who like and she's a successful actress
but like clearly loves playing this role
right right it's very fun for her all
right so I want to see nebula dance more
yeah more dancing than uh this one
despite what Tommy says there's no way
they're killing a dog hear me out
[Music]
hear him out
they gotta slit that down
listen Disney wasn't like Cruella killed
two dogs okay
if anybody if anybody's pissing pants if
anybody's pissing fans it's the dog that
has to wear an astronauts
contributor maybe we've got a uh no
guess who's Hank coming in to be a great
Cosmo no
the only thing Hank's gonna die from is
scarfing down wieners I think I think
also in there I think Cosmo's similar to
Groot costume is gonna be a big hit with
kids yeah a lot of toys there's gonna be
a talking Cosmo toy in the Disney World
and you don't shop and it doesn't
a brand new character it doesn't
there's no way they touch Cosmo he's
yeah yeah
is Cosmo a boy voiced by a woman
it's a grown woman yeah yeah I think
they're establishing maybe Cosmo is
female yeah in this I love it Cosmo a
[ __ ] confirmed wow that's what they're
called does she bleed oh God okay now
now we've that's too far thumbnail
thumbnail it's the thumbnail
natural things that happen to animals
I'm sorry that was clearly been fixed
listen Tommy should lead only this she
was fixed by the uh the high
evolutionary that's the only thing he
did though he's like I just got to
control the pet population Adam Warlock
yeah
he's signed on for the franchise is that
true yeah he signed up for more movies
yeah I thought I didn't do those for
anyone anymore well guess what and again
like to kill off a character we just got
introduced feels unlikely but there was
a long history of killing off villains
right thrown in the accuser got killed
off that's true but then he came back in
Captain Marvel he doesn't know like I
like you said he's a dumb baby so he's
not he doesn't know that he's doing
wrong yet and I think once he does
that's when it will hit him but also
Adam Warlock just works with so many
people in the comics don't kill off that
character is there even a chance I was
thinking like it's wild at the three MCU
movies we're getting next year are kind
of all like Fantastical space I know
technically quantumania is not outer
space it's in like super Inner Space but
both the Marvels and Guardians are outer
space movies at least partially so like
could he even show up in the Marvels
and Marvel could come across him so
easily and she has in the comics so I
would love that and and Adam Warlock has
been in at least some of the iterations
of the Guardians yeah right yeah so like
maybe if they're setting up this is a
little bit like Avengers leading into
Young Avengers if you know Cosmos
mantis right might be kind of part of a
new team yeah yeah one or under yeah
yeah I think we got to give him an
upside down dead he's going to be in
combat and anyone who's going to be in
combat technically has a chance to Die
the upside down means not very likely I
like the two people we gave zero two so
far Cosmo and Group Well quite frankly
dogs love to fetch so Groot would it
would be fine with Cosmos High Evolution
65. the remaining yandus on the board
he seems like purely evil villain right
that character is so good and such a
madman and I I don't think we have that
many genetic biologists in the MCU yet
or like ones that are doing it to the
Mad Men I feel like we're overstuffed
with genetic biologists in the MCU I
could name at least just the one that
you said okay I'm sorry and so I just I
I want him to stay forever yes and it
will be a fun character and that actor
is great but we also know part of the
Arc of Rocket I will say the one thing
that could save him is if Rocket's Ark
is he goes to kill the high evolutionary
to get Vengeance but the ultimate lesson
he learns is to spare the high Evolution
and then Drax comes in and stabs
yeah I'm kind of expecting is the high
evolutionary to be like what I did I
gave you life as like a human almost
like you own you're an animal that can
walk yeah but it was so painful he talks
about how painful yeah no that's what
I'm saying I think that made me a freak
I think that rocket is going to go to
that planet and though those that planet
is going to be like under high
evolutionaries control I think a lot of
those people are like well I like being
able to do whatever the freedoms that I
have is a half human half and Marvel's
done a great job of like justifying all
the villains actions yeah like uh we
have run some polls in the chat you know
the chat seems to agree that like
crackling in the high evolutionary are
doomed uh nebula that God nebula had 44
you guys barely got there whoa wow a
rocket here's the other thing you know
you have uh James Gunn saying not all of
them are gonna make it right we're
killing off like craglin I'm ancillary
Guardian of the Galaxy well Drax is a
core member
that's very safe guys we know Batista
I think I think mantis is gonna die and
you all for food I I you know well pooed
it my only thing with mantis is they
really powered her up but I do see what
you're saying no we'll bumper up to
don't feel any more pain I also think
Peter qua has a higher chance of dying
yes
I think we got to add another one to
that too I agree also they gotta slit
that dogs
the chat agrees Groot very low
likelihood categories uh good morning I
want to hear the higher evolutionaries
like we just said like they they do a
good job of rationalizing all the bad
guys but I wanted to be like my whole
life all I dreamed of was giving breasts
to a pig and then 10 fingers and ten
toes I wanted to see an ostrich wear a
skirt all I wanted to do was put some
Tommy Hilfiger jokes out of koala the
thing is I agree with the ostrich in a
skirt that's kind of cute I want a panda
to pay the homeowners association as a
boy I went to Build-A-Bear Workshop and
there any animal could have any career I
wanted I swore I want to see a Jeep
Grand Cherokee being driven by an otter
um uh yeah it's a Jeep thing you
wouldn't understand
um wow well we're gonna see again this
movie's coming out May of 2023 so uh a
scant six months from now yeah we'll get
confirmation on these maybe further
trailers will give us more kind of Clues
and hints
um real quick uh speaking of the LA
Comic Con where we're gonna be on Sunday
we'd love to see you there if you can
make it
um our friends over at the epic hero
shop they have a cool new product they
uh are are putting out called the
convast and it's a vest that you wear to
conventions now this is not necessarily
my size but I'm gonna put it on I must
confess I love that convast it looks
great on you yeah and like if you could
tell the the wording here on the uh kind
of the lapel is it's different uh
fictional languages there's wakandan
orabash uh I think the Elven language
from The Lord of the Rings is in there
and like you can see we put some enamel
pins on here these are pins sold by the
epic hero shop pins patches you can do
it yes and the members of the break room
crew signed it there's a um whose
signature is that
oh that's Jessica's signature signature
with a nice little heart freehand uh
myself and Tommy said Brandon have you
signed this not yet okay so we're gonna
try and track Brandon back you can uh if
you were we were also yelling uh he was
too busy cutting out uh
and the Deadpool logo that we did not
need appeared on its own we also have
some patches and some other pins we're
gonna put on this and you can enter to
win it for free you just have to go to
the link that's in this video's
description I think it's epic hero shop
uh.com slash Pages slash Converse
contest convast I spelled it out uh put
in your email address and you can enter
to win they're going to ship you that
exact one that's signed by us and we'll
have pins and patches already applied to
it you should check out all the other
merch that they have for sale there uh
uh Christian unpronounceable sign in a
Super Chat thing rocket has to
personally kill the high evolutionary
for making him yes you got to kill your
man I agree you gotta kill your maker
match 143 saying do not slip the dogs
choice and I agree uh Corey can't can
drilly suggest a Groot slinging wood
like a lumberjack competition
Miss Mack Daddy uh will we have a
Wednesday inspired break room we'd like
that'd be some fun cosplay to do we have
a Wednesday inspired breakdown oh coming
out on the channel keep your eyes peeled
uh can we all do the dance
um corrupted next asking would Adam have
the ego Stone slash gem instead of Soul
oh wait wait wait say it again you know
the ego Stone I don't know is that is
that from ego The Living Planet does he
have a stone I don't know I know the I
my whole theory about that is I watched
James again because again this is his
last movie and then he's going off to DC
he's like peace out [ __ ] you um I think
he's going what was it like
I think he's gonna make it I I like that
in the comics they also there's so many
names for the Soul Gem and they just
call it the soul Jewel and then we just
have it now as the soul jewels in his
head and people are gonna be like it's
the soul gem it's a soul Stone and
they're gonna be like no it's not it's
just called the soldier it's the same
thing I think he's just gonna troll us
is what I'm basically saying he's gonna
he's gonna come for us and that's that
gem is gonna I think it's Soju and if
you push it a little Soju comes out I
was gonna say I drink too much Soju yeah
delicious Korean alcoholic beverage I
think James Gunn is going to kill off a
lot of the characters yeah more than
we've even said oh and then so let's
take a picture of this for people he's
gonna walk out and then zazlov's gonna
send a message to Kevin feige it's like
telling it you know
I famously had the salsa and yada yada
yada he was part of the infinity war in
the comic books but the fact that the
character still has something there is
very interesting yeah I mean because he
could have just made the character
without it no one would have known he
still painted gold he's still
recognizable yeah let's real quick so
over under number of characters listed
on this board that will die we also did
not list Aisha we did not list the
Sylvester Stallone ravager character you
know there's some side characters does
John C Reilly show back up just to be
whacked or going close we don't know um
I don't know yeah it's not pissing my
pants that's John C Riley I'm a record
by the way we're about two and a half
dollars away from our next impression
wheel we might spin it for you
we got it okay let's spin that I got him
wait real quick before before as time is
fitting it total number of these
characters that will die in this movie I
think like it's much higher I think like
four characters we got we got two major
deaths in wakanda forever right one of
which we did not expect I certainly did
not whoa four characters homelander
homelander come on
damn typecasted let's hope what's
homelander doing homelander is getting
kicked out of a restaurant in Spain yeah
would take an hour okay but not not the
muscles oh my God we're so good at it
if I don't get two pictures of sangria
stack I'm gonna break everybody's neck
in here Commander was asked to perform
uh at a basketball game but he gets
there and turns out it's a WNBA game and
not an NBA game okay I was told to come
to the arena formerly known as Staples
currently known as I believe exact Tech
Arena all right I would assume I would
be here for a Lakers game for a Clippers
game me me even
a Kings game
but I show up I homelander show up and
it's the Sparks
okay okay one more one more
thinks he's getting invited to a
TalkBack of The Empire Strikes Back with
George Lucas but he's actually invited
to a screening of a food parody the
Empire splits the back of my pants with
George fukis
[Laughter]
okay also I do acknowledge I don't
assume he's already saying this in the
chat this is not a great homelander
impression no it's just me being an
entitled white guy which is the
character it's pretty easy for me to
Trail okay
um okay well
that alone is good
hi
[Music]
all the way here to the New Beverly
Cinema okay you know what traffic's like
on La Brea you flew yes but
I flew all the way here okay Expecting
The Empire Strikes Back arguably the
best in the Star Wars franchise and
instead I'm here for it yeah
this is not even one of the better
course mucus Vehicles we're gonna need a
bigger banana boat that was clearly what
it is better George Focus Vehicles we're
clearly um Raiders of the Lost pork okay
it was obviously
um the fan of meatus George pukus didn't
even direct uh the Empire Sports in the
back of my pants frick
hey
um also why is nobody watching candy ore
George I can't stop pissing my pants
they better slit that dog's throat okay
uh it's beautiful it's not a Friday
break room until it goes a little bit
off the rails that was an excellent Zach
thank you uh thank you to everybody
sending in super chats today uh Nate
Nate Nate Dodson uh Miles Kennedy TD
Jones you Capri to everybody uh sunny
and everybody in there watch the show
all week yeah super fun week we were so
thrilled and excited to get those
trailers yesterday
um hopefully fingers crossed we get some
more in December to freak out about
um and oh uh real quick
also if you if you're still watching hit
like And subscribe on this video please
next Friday a week from today we're
going to be having our first annual
break room holiday party
holiday party yes yeah you'll see a
heightened version of of these these
these trees would be just just tall
enough to block out all of us
um and uh we've got some fun stuff
planned for that so be sure to tune in
next week and and next Friday join us
for the holiday party anything else we
need to plug I just want to say don't
say it I'm so grateful to be with all of
you around Christmas time and all I want
for Christmas is
fine oh keep an eye out things coming on
the channels dogs are watching Eric's uh
Guardians uh volume three breakdown
trailer breakdowns out on the channel
now Jessica has a couple exciting videos
coming out including one that I believe
involves our own Tommy Bechtel
can I say it sure we break down the
Transformers trailer yeah yeah that's
right rise of the beasts is that this
subtitle yeah yeah and the trailer as
well George buchus was uh rise of the
East
you know George fukis said about the
first Transformers movie
uh George Duke has no relation to Matt
gookas actual NBA player okay uh uh okay
okay
George Lucas are there any other vomit
themed famous Hollywood directors he
made American barfini there's Steven
spielsberg
uh what what uh uh the butt hurled by
Lee Daniels uh well I mean because the
actress Elizabeth Hurley yes of course
and then there's Elizabeth spew uh from
from the from the boys from the boys
Yeah Yeah from the first season uh um
there's there's Chloe oh I'm gonna puke
it's gonna close you out yeah
Patty barfons uh she's pretty great yeah
oh okay yeah all right well I think I
think we've properly wasted another
three minutes I think I think we
evacuated uh enough of that um okay
thank you all so much there it is did we
did we yeah thank goodness Robert's
that's it at least it's not the porn
parody
now can we get Forest Hump should we
combine the puke director and the
foreign
uh uh okay George puke is directing
Empire Strikes all over my back oh my
God hey yo
apologies uh apologies
I'll probably use the indoor uh have a
great weekend everybody ready
[Music]
[Music]